all right Tony he's gone Tony where you
from originally
where'd you grow up I'm originally from
Victorville California summer Rd no
County did you have both your parents
growing up I had both my parents growing
up and just my father he was absent from
most of my life you know he's in the
military was very violent and uh he left
my side about nine years old
when you see left ready to go he went to
prison federal prison because uh he was
a manufacturing drugs and stuff like
that so you know he was taken away from
us you know and how was your childhood
otherwise it was good it was uh
I grew up as a Christian guy you know I
was uh I was in the music industry with
the band and stuff a Christian band nest
and that's what I did most of my
childhood was which was a big part of
your upper yeah it was part of my life
in it was a big part of my life and um
with my extra time I was uh doing my
schoolwork and I was in track and field
in wrestling and I had I had a pretty
good childhood my mom she was always uh
devoted to us and um she never really
concentrated anything else but us and um
you know I all I could do is a thank my
mom for a reason it's the best way she
could you know there's a six of us and
I'm single parent she went to school she
got educated and um she was I don't know
how she did it but a single mom it would
raise us all and you know it was it's
quick we live pretty poor and you know I
mean a good meal for us was
Top Ramen for you know that's pretty
much what it was you know and I mean
although it was tougher and I appreciate
her and I know she had a hard time you
know but my childhood was rough you know
I was brought up fairly well as in I'm a
3.9 student
I almost got my 4.0 like within all my
years I was really uh I was a I was a
good kid you know I was uh one of the
best I could say because that's what I
always thrived for was you know I was
really competitive you know and I always
wanted to be the best you know you know
and I and I did that but you know I made
some decisions long down the road which
be I became Who I am today which is
pretty you know some of my friends would
ask me what happened what made that
change you know and um you know I made
it and now I got to live with it but you
know I could go from negative to
positive you know and within my
experiences that I have experienced now
I plan on somehow trying to like I see
myself helping the youth or anything
like that you know what I mean like now
within my experiences in prison and the
things that I went through I believe I
could turn into something positive and
help other kids that you know have you
know the background of the gang life or
you know drug use you know all so forth
like that you know and that's what I
plan on doing now you know because this
wasn't the plan but sometimes you know
life throws a curveball at you and
sometimes you know and and somebody
somebody smart he told me you know do
you know the difference between a major
league baseball player and a minor
league baseball player
well myolie can't
a curveball but a major-league player
can hit that curveball so now that the
ball is thrown at me and it's a curve
it's a pretty fast one and now I gotta
learn how just swinging and hit it you
know and that's what I'm doing today is
trying to turn this in this bad
experience into something positive you
know and when I made this decision I
don't know if I should go now with my
story is uh I was younger and I was 18
years old and I came home one day me my
buddies were hanging out up at the house
and um you know I'll go hey Rob let me
see your phone man because I my phones
inside charging he's he looked a little
bit worried but he's like here you go
and he passes me his phone and then he
goes here you go and and I happen to
notice somebody kept texting them and
I'm like huh I wonder so I look over at
his phone and I pick it up and I look at
the phone and I was like I noticed it
was my baby sister's phone number I like
what the [ __ ]
so so so I started thinking to myself
okay should I be nosy or whatever so so
I grab it and I click on it and it
happens to me my baby sister texting
this man and she was at the time only 13
years old and this man's 30 and it
happened to be about sexual things it
was like oh your bomb your this and that
I mean it was consensual but at the same
time he manipulated her into believing
that they would have a life somewhere
along the road and stuff like that and
so so it was shocking to me in a cold
chill came over me like oh my god I
can't believe this [ __ ] so what I do is
I say I look at her and I I decided in
that moment okay I'm gonna get this guy
so so I like we need more drinks because
this guy was pretty big you know
I mean he was bigger than me so I'm like
hell no [ __ ] am I gonna do this one you
know so I I came up with a quick plan
and I was like let's get him drunk so we
start drinking up in the garage and I
got him pretty drunk and it came to that
moment where my buddy he was in the
garage he looks at me and I already ran
it down to him and so I hit the garage
door and he he knows something's up
because he's like oh I think I'm gonna
go now and I'm like all right give me a
second
so I go inside and I know this is kinda
it gets a little graphic and a little um
bad but I grab an ice pick so when he
decides to leave he yawns like this you
i'ma leave like this and when he did
that yawn I stabbed him three times I
stabbed him three times and after that I
started just stomping him out and within
that moment I thought of putting in can
in his mouth so I put the can in his
mouth like this and I kick it which
dislocated his jaw to his mouth and the
count went into his mouth and by this
time I thought he was dead when you say
can a can of beer can
Oh beer can a complete full beer can
went into his mouth which I got up and
just into his mouth and rip this whole
mouth open and by that time he was pail
white he wasn't breathing
I thought and I look over my wife opens
the garage door and she's like oh my god
so and I go
get the [ __ ] out and she shuts the door
immediately and then
she she comes back this is what's crazy
this girl loved me so much where she
comes back with rubber gloves and bleach
Hey
she started cleaning up all the blood
she's like freaking out she's like oh my
god Tony what what are we gonna do like
what the hell why did you do this and
I'm like just just relax relax so I go
grab the the living room carpet we grab
this guy
well I grabbed this guy nobody else was
involved I grab this guy and I start
rolling them in the carpet the rug the
rug and um I dragged this guy into my
car throw him in the trunk and drive him
out to the middle of nowhere which was
Barstow in the desert by this time this
man is still out cold and I toss him out
thank God somebody must have looked
somebody up there must have loved this
guy because when for this man to
actually get back up from whatever I did
and I thought I got away with it because
I'm I'm in my living room you know this
is it's a little long down the road a
month later I thought it got away with
it everybody's calling me hey have you
seen Robert I'm like nah haven't seen
him my brother's like hey Tony you're
the last one with him and his family
keeps calling us and I'm like I have no
idea
and all these charges already been
convicted of so so there's no there's no
convicted or any crime here because I
did my time and uh so so his family's
calling and I thought I got away with it
and next thing you know I'm sitting back
in my room my living room and my door
gets kicked in it's it's cops the cops
come in and they're like you know why
we're here I'm like no I [ __ ] III
don't do anything you know what I mean
so they come in they're like
we're here because your last scene with
Robert Lopez and and this is where where
they got me is that I was like I thought
that dude was gone and they're like no
he's been in ICU he's been in test
intensive care high desert hospital I
was like oh okay and so why are you guys
here and they look at me and they're
like you really don't know I'm like I
have no clue
well Robert Lopez said that you were
with him last and that you heard him and
by that time I was like okay I'm [ __ ]
but I went along with it and I said I
had no idea but I did occur imminent
myself by saying I was with him and this
is where it starts
you know they arrest me I go to jail and
within that time in jail I my first my
first deal on the table was 25 to life
because they got me for premeditated and
torturing a victim so I was looking at
25 to life and within that time I fought
it for 16 months I was lucky to get
cellie that was all about law you know
and he says you know what Tony you
shouldn't be reading them stupid books
you know I was reading a lot of James
Patterson you know all those crazy books
and stuff you know and uh he he tells me
you should get read more stuff that gets
you out of here which was the law and so
I started learning more about law and
stuff and um so I learned that and when
I went into the courtroom and this is
further along down which I'm gonna try
to speed it up for you is uh I went the
second time court and then they're like
mr. Michaels well we got a deal on the
table for you right now if you sign 40
years we'll take the life sentence sauce
and I was like well can I wait some time
because I need to think about this and
you talk
my wife and and I didn't I didn't know
they were still investigating me because
they wanted to see if I was crazy or if
I if I had a different motive because I
did explain to him what happened he
molested my little sister and stuff and
and what what got me out was he had a
phone
the victim had the phone and and and I
kept it I kept it because I was gonna I
was to be honest I was gonna sell it
cluck it whatever you want to call it
you know what I mean I was gonna get
some money out of it and they put it on
a monitor and when they put it on the
monitor they're looking to place me to
make sure that I had no way out to place
me within the spot that the victim was
hurt they wanted to place me there with
the phone by by tracing it but while
they ran it new evidence were found
which were naked pictures of my baby
sister and I was like holy [ __ ] this guy
is telling the truth
so by neck my third court date I go in
and the DA did something that they never
do
- nobody if anybody knows what I'm
talking about that DA just sits there
and watches you you know and doesn't say
a thing and just convicts you and gives
you your time well this DA actually gets
up walks over to me and says mr.
Michaels you know the only difference
between me new today is is I would have
killed that [ __ ] and I was like
whoa like that's crazy like dia never
says no [ __ ] like that but he says the
only reason why we're giving you time
today is because you could have handled
it differently and you could you know
but you really hurt that guy and I
really did and unfortunately he didn't
die but but I'm sorry I all I could do
is pray for the guy and hope that he
makes better decisions along down the
line but so so then he comes at me well
there's a new deal on the table and
that's
twenty years without life and I look
over at my wife she's crying but she was
happy because I'm not gonna spend the
rest of my life in prison I sign these
20 years and I net doing 15 out of those
20 because you know I went from all-out
church boy to now being introduced to
prison life which now I'm all tatted up
and uh I've learned the the bad way of
life you could say you know because I
didn't learn anything good because when
you go to prison you you you start to do
things that you don't want to and that's
why I ended up doing 15 instead of 10
because it was my first conviction and I
ended up catching five years for three
institutional stabbings you know and and
sometimes you have to do that you know
if anybody knows anything about prison
like when it comes to your time to put
in your work you gotta put it in even
though you don't want to it's something
that you have to do you sometimes it's
kind of fun participating in it but you
know my last five years were segregated
I was in a I was in Cork and shoe which
they call it the green wall the hardest
prison you could go to is the hardest
ad-seg su that you could possibly go to
a tall concrete the oniy person you see
is the deputy and sometimes sometimes
you're so freakin bored when they're
walking by you need somebody to talk to
so you're like hey what's up deputy hey
how you doing you know try and get any
words out of them because you're in that
block concrete room that little slot
they really make you feel like you're in
segregated ICU and so so I would do that
and I spent my time working out and
doing that but
I did those 15 and it was it's crazy
because when I got out I I got out and I
came to just it was different everything
changed on me you know like now now I
have a gang background I've I've
acquired a lot of different new hobbies
as in drug addiction of I became
something that I didn't really want to
be but I mean I wouldn't change the
decision I made it because I mean I felt
that it was something good that I did
good for my little baby sister because
otherwise she would went another route
within her life she'd been stuck with
this 30 year old man that had nothing
going on for himself you know and did he
ever molest her yeah yeah he molested
her and that's why I did that was
because uh before I caught that case he
he he was taking advantage of her while
we were gone me my mom and stuff and him
and his girlfriend would babysit my
sister and while we were all gone
thinking everything's okay he was having
sex with her you know he was
manipulating her he he made her fall in
love with him and by that time she she's
she's thinking this guy loves her and
you know she had no idea I mean the girl
was only 13 you know she was only 13
years old when all this was going on in
you know when all that happened I mean
now she don't talk to me I would she she
would and know that I'm not mad at
but now she's just I think embarrassed
or whatever he kind of messed up her
head you know and I feel bad for her but
you know it's something we both got live
with I guess you know but yeah that was
how my story ended up and um I went
along with now I got live with this and
I got turn it positive because it I
don't know they're this living in living
and destruction were self destructive to
ourselves and uh you know getting
addicted to all these drugs and stuff
like that it goes nowhere you end up
with nothing you know because before
this I was a working guy you know I was
everything I did was involved in church
and then like I said I went to prison
and it just I started learning how to
deal drugs going in print the prison
system how to make money within the
system you know if you know anybody
knows confirmation would get in prison
we collect confirmation numbers you know
we we get the dope through freaking
guises uh people bring it through their
ass or whatever they do and they bring
it in to us the ones that have the back
job and we break it up in the prison
system and we so little little specks
for a hundred bucks and when somebody
wants to buy something they got to come
with a confirmation number you know and
a confirmation number it which is the
green dots that's how we make money in
prison and we send it out to our family
members and then they ship it back into
us put it on books or whatever and
that's how we buy things that's how we
get cell phones that's how you know the
system moves that's how we become
productive by being locked down because
you know you want to be able to being a
man want to be able to still provide for
your family you know so whatever way we
always find a way and that's how I did
it was start trafficking heroin
throughout the system you know and I was
the dope man in the system and yeah it
was kind of cool because I was making a
lot of money you know I was making a lot
of money within you know I'd get a
quarter ounce and make you know 12,000
bucks within a month period you know and
it was it was cool you know but still
still that money went so quick you know
like when I got out you know I had think
I had I had a house I had my cars and
every everything was there it was
successful to me and I met a lot of
different type of people and I came out
thinking I could be the same guy that I
was in prison because now I know all
these connections where I could be the
dope man you know and if you guys look
me up you know I was I was busted for
for drugs and they considered me the
kingpin when I was on the streets and I
thought it was funny because when when I
got busted for that they set out how to
drug a drug ring which wasn't a drug
ring I was just selling dope you know
and um it turned out - now now I learned
how to do that and I was able to provide
to my family within that but it turned
into something else because if anybody
knows about the the dope game you know
you're still breaking the law you're
still doing this and that and I started
off you know okay you know and then
[Music]
people started you know dying on me as
in like as we went along down I'm trying
to direct this story and keep it on
track you know and uh so so when I got
out we started
and I've met a few people we met up from
the prison system they happen to be
somebodies you know and they start
providing drugs to me at a cheap price
which I was in Victorville and I started
moving in traffic in it and and within
that time I guess I was stupid because I
was allowing a lot of traffic to come to
my house a lot of people were coming to
my house and in it
the cops were we're monitoring me now
you know and and I had no idea you know
I had no idea that feds
when when they're watching you or the
cops are watching you that they actually
have the mailman as as an undercover
well you think it's just a mailman
coming by to to drop off mail no that's
the cause you know and they're freaking
good at what they freaking do because I
I I honestly didn't believe some of my
friends are like hey Tony you you need
to freaking uh stop using your phone
line because they're there what they're
watching you and I was like nah that's
impalas only movies you know and uh now
sure enough my daughter gets kicked in
again and the cops come in and they have
pictures of everybody that came to my
house everybody even myself they had
paid they had me looking like I was a
friend a supermodel or something I was
so many pictures I'm like God where did
they get these pictures you know like
and sure enough I find out the mailman
the guy that was putting up the the
signs the guy that was just walking down
the street with the dog there are all
the cops and they ended up taking me
down for that and if anybody wants to
know if this story is true just look up
Tony Michaels online under F seven seven
five nine three that's my prison number
and I do have a great bodily injury to
create great bodily harm with a weapon
and I do have a drug trafficking charge
because when they caught me they caught
me with the kilo and a half of heroin
and $5,000 in my pocket and that's all
online right now with that you know and
um that being said you know I mean is
there any more questions on that
so where's your life today how my life
is today it's going better you know I'm
trying I'm trying to get on track with
it you know I'm trying to bounce back
from doing what I did now I'm trying to
do different trying to stay sober and
I'm trying to just get my life back in
by doing that I'm trying to figure out
some hobbies like working out and uh you
know I guess I gotta get back to the way
I used to live which that that's kind of
forgotten you know because it's been so
long because I did do 15 years and um
just got out how old you know I'm 33
years old and when that happened I was
18 9 going to 19 I was young and I'm now
now now it's kind of it's kind of hard
but at the same time you know who who
can say it's hard if you're not taking
that first step you know like that
that's what we have the tendency of
doing we're saying we're gonna do this
we're gonna do that we're but we never
take that first step you know and that's
what I gotta do now I got a man up leave
the [ __ ] alone stop its associating
myself with the people because within
that I I've seen I don't know if anybody
knows who Joel Osteen is he says it on
his uh on one of his sermons he says if
if you wanna you know be a chicken you
could be a chicken but if you want to
soar like eagle you could swore like the
eagle it's who you surround yourself
with you know what I mean if you want to
kick it with some frickin bums best no
you're gonna become a bum
you know what I mean if you want to hang
out with well this is my advice to
everybody is if you want to hang out and
you want to do better in life start
hanging out with winners people that are
doing something people that have
something going on for themselves maybe
you're not doing it you know but
surround yourselves with that people
with those people and eventually you
will be doing that you know eventually
you will have that car or whatever it is
that that your goals are in life that
could be it
you know because you know Kobe Bryant he
this I know he just passed away but Kobe
said something important that affected
me in life which was you know when you
feel tired when you feel like giving up
when you feel you don't like you don't
even want do it anymore
like that's when you do it that's when
you go forward and you push yourself and
you get that accomplished because that's
when your dreams will come true and
that's what he said when you feel tired
and feel like not doing it get up and do
it and that's when you'll start seeing
your dreams come true
and it's true you know that's that's
where they went when I feel like giving
up or I feel like just saying [ __ ] it
and taking that hit and getting high
again or whatever it is that I feel like
doing and that's just throwing in the
towel but I mean I need to push forward
and get on with my life and just stop
letting my past because my father wasn't
there or whatever you know because you
know a lot of us do that is we we let
our past affect us today we we got we
gotta just leave that alone
stop wasting your todays in your
problems of yesterday you know what I
mean because we can't do that no more we
got we got to forget about it you know I
mean just leave that alone and just use
that as the past and move on forward and
live with your life in and you know
light like myself now now I I don't talk
to people when it when I say oh I went
to prison 15 years on bad ass not it's
not
about that anymore I use it as a past
experience as to you know what maybe you
don't want to go that route because you
know I went that route and there's
nothing in it you know like and that's
what I do is now now it's just a
testimony for me you know now it's only
for for somebody that's hurting out
there and that's what I try to do I try
to try to make positive at it because
you know down like that we can't we
can't just stay in emotion and let her
pass affect us anymore we got we got to
go forward you know and um it's
unfortunate that my dad wasn't there but
you know what whatever he's going
through or whatever he had to you went
to prison and he did his time doesn't
mean I got to do that and be absent to
my children you know and you know III
believe that it's gonna get better you
know because you know I don't want to
put any I don't want to put no God's
name or anything because who knows he's
watching this video they could be Muslim
or whatever and that's not me we're
we're all thriving for the same thing
just for peace and tranquility and
bettering our lives and that's why we
believe in a God you know so are you
still using heroin no I I quit heroin
I've been two years off you know how'd
you get off it
how did I get off it to be honest I got
addicted to something else which was
weed marijuana I smoked weed but I mean
I look at it like it's legal and um yeah
it's it's bad you know but at the same
time I believe it's not as bad as heroin
you know do you have kids now I have a
daughter I have two daughters two
daughters and uh it's unfortunate that I
was that absent from my 15 year old
daughter seven
well [ __ ] yeah she's going 17 now
17 and um you know Natalie she she she's
I'm proud of her I love her it's just I
I don't want to go into her life right
now because I feel like I'm gonna shock
her me so she's so smart and she's gonna
you know she's doing things for herself
which I don't wanna
IIIi don't know if I'm doing bad for her
or I'm doing good but I feel that if I
come into her life she's gonna look at
me like dude what's up with my dad you
know like I got tatted up I'm not really
doing too good so I I don't know how to
explain to her that I'm scared to you
know let her know me you know because of
the decisions that my I made in um you
know and it scares me but eventually I I
want to talk to her and I'm waiting for
her to just get through schooling and
she she continues on the right path you
know because yeah she's doing good and
I'm hoping yeah thank you so much for
talking with me Tony thank you well good
luck with everything
you